so that certain speaker is Adams Kauai
from Microsoft research is crossing
everybody alright thank you so much for
inviting me I was gonna debating between
talking about this and some work and
meta learning but I feel like this is
more it's a little bit older work but
it's more on the topic of the workshop
so this is joint work with a bunch of
people here you can see several of them
are here come Alika and savannah
probably here maybe others and okay
let's just jump right in so the crowd is
I would say still useful today
so here's a funny picture of Barack
Obama playing a trick on somebody and if
you were to ask the crowd to and if you
were to ask the crowd to get ready
caption for this they would probably say
you know Barack Obama plays a corrupt
clever prank on somebody he's stepping
on the scale so that this guy will think
he's heavier than he is right but if you
would ask a neural net to caption this
it would Pratt you know even the best
neural net today like what would the
best caption be it would be something
like it would recognize that that's
Barack Obama that he's smiling he's but
you know something like Barack Obama
smiles and watches a man weigh himself
in the locker room okay which is not a
very good caption if you're trying to
describe this picture to somebody that'd
be very evoke all kinds of other images
and their mind
so okay so the crowd is the point of the
crowd still has a rich understanding of
the real world in ways that that machine
learning algorithms are far from
understanding and we'll see if they can
help help help machine learning
algorithms understand the world better
okay so I'll give you another example of
something more recent that I've been
working on where we use crowdsourcing so
okay there's a lot of ways in which I've
made the title of crowdsourcing
machinery I'm not gonna able to cover
all the applications of crowdsourcing
machine learning and one of the most
basic applications is just having a
crowd label data okay but the crowd can
label data either captioning they can
also label things in in just much better
ways and more efficiently than
then-then-then other approaches so
here's an example where we were using
the crowd in a fun way so there are
these things called word embeddings
which probably many of you have heard of
right okay and they the word embeddings
our way of representing words as vectors
in space and then you can do cool vector
if meta can the word embeddings can
actually answer questions like man is to
King as woman is to Queen Paris is to
France as Tokyo is to and then it pops
out with Japan and it sorta has these
parallelogram structure to these
embeddings so we noticed that that
there's problems with these word
embeddings that they're actually
captured biases that are present in
society so it says he is too blue as she
is - what does it pop out with anyone
goes
asmath country he is too brother as she
is - he is - doctor as she is - yeah it
comes out with nurse used to programmer
as she is to homemaker and trump would
be happy with that so actually I made
this slide before trumpets president so
here's the pregnant use the pregnancy
here's the pregnant serious here's Jerry
stone anyway there's a bunch of them
that are interesting and problematic
these were didn't better just mentioned
this is a serious topic is these weird
embeddings are actually used in a lot of
places and so if you're ranking resumes
and you're happy with the fact that the
word programmer is closer to JavaScript
than it is to piper then you know
something else that's great JavaScript
Python but it's also closer to John than
Mary which is a problem so there's no
hope it's a topic of another paper but
um we use the crowd just for example
here to very quickly and efficiently it
can tell us which things here represent
stereotypes in which which analogies are
actually just you know definitional
analogies that might make sense I can
show you actually it kind of is another
we made a little demo out of this and
see if this works and actually it's kind
of fun because um there is some active
learning here which we didn't do but I
think is a neat future work so I'll just
mention it now so here you can put in a
couple words like let's put in Berkeley
and Harvard and it's going to find a
bunch of related words and and split
them by gender I don't know if you can
see that so it's trying to find I guess
what I was hoping I would find a bunch
of universities which it did and it sort
of maps them out by by which ones are
more associated with he on the left and
which ones are more associated with XI
so it looks like CMU is a very masculine
University and MIT Wharton and a lot of
Wesley Wellesley is very feminine anyway
interesting but I'm kind of a fun
question here is is an active learning
question here obviously
how would you enter in an interactive
fashion get a better list of words here
even even ignoring the gender so the
word embeddings are really fun and I
think the the the neat thing about word
embeddings from an active learning point
of view is that what I just did is I
wasn't labeling examples I was coming up
with examples from my mind right so I
might say oh okay there's a problem here
that certain category is missing and I
could just invent a word from my mind
pull it out of thin air as opposed to
most active learning where you label
examples okay but back to crowdsourcing
so crowdsourcing there's a lot of work
on one aspect of crowdsourcing that I'm
not going to go into because it's less
relevant to this workshop I think which
is just labels getting the crowd to
label data okay
and I call it judgment now to label
because people might not agree it's it's
not it's you know you could get ten
different labels from ten different
people and you might get ten ten
different answers so and it's an
interesting area and there's a lot of
cool work on this and there's sort of a
very common eeehm algorithm that's used
and then a bunch of ways to improve on
that and I'm not going to go into that
today one aspect that a sivan and i
worked on here which was fun is which is
different when you actually interact
with these people is exactly in this
fact that people give you different
answers so here we had a fun problem
where we said let's see if we can get
people to build a classifier or actually
a regression regressor to estimate how
much I weigh from a picture of me or
anyone from picture of themselves okay
and there's a website where people post
their own pictures and say how much they
weigh so we took data from there and we
said okay let's build a classifier that
said guess how much somebody weighs from
a picture of them but the thing is
different people will have different
estimates so in crowdsourcing the wisdom
of the crowds would just say let's just
ask everyone to guess how much they
weigh and average that that would be one
option but maybe we could do better
so let's imagine that we have a budget
we can ask you know ten questions right
so we can ask ten people how much this
person weighs or we could ask five
people how much this person weighs we
could ask two people whether the person
is pretty and one person whether they're
male or female and two people whether a
good pass
and we can actually get a better
classifier so you know we have an
algorithm there which I won't go into
the details but given a bunch of
features we decide how many people this
number here means how many people do we
ask for each feature how many people
should we ask each each each question to
so that we get the the most accurate
classifier we can using the budget and
by the way feel free to interrupt I'd
rather not finish the talk and have an
interesting discussion then get all the
way get a lot all the way through you
just try to predict wait with all these
artists yeah so we had maybe more
features maybe we had ten features and
we would create create a label dataset
where we asked many people on a small
set to estimate each of these features
and we could see how much people tend to
agree or disagree and how predictive
each feature is and then from that we
could figure out what the best regressor
is so this means ask five people to
estimate their weight an average it the
5/2 means ask two people to ask if that
person is pretty one person you only
need to ask one person to say they
gender typically because people can
there's a lot of agreement on that even
though there might be a systematic under
estimate or over estimate based on
gender might be very predictive you
might still need to ask one person
because there's a lot of agreement when
you say that's a great question
we chose the features here but that's a
great segue to the rest of the talk okay
because we should have the crowd suggest
the features you're right we didn't
think of doing it there but it that we
will I will talk about that now and
there were stuff so that's exactly the
issue what are the steps in machine
learning one is choosing representation
for the data which now I will talk about
exactly your question of who choose the
features we can crowdsource we can get
the crowd seduced not use their
brilliant minds to help us choose a good
representation that's exactly where they
have a big advantage over computers
right they can label data of course as I
mentioned and they we can round existing
machine learning algorithms on that data
so the different types of representation
I'll talk about are either sort of a
feature based one the you know where we
have a bunch of features like in that
exam
full of gender info on them which could
be binary or a real-valued you could
also have a kernel based sort of
similarity oh this person is like that /
we could have asked people questions you
know how you question so there's a
either you have two options one option
is you can if it's so imagine you have a
data set of products okay and you have
images for each product one option is
you get a new product and you have
people label all those features for the
product or tell how similar it is to
previous products another option is you
first use the crowd to get the features
and then you train classifiers to
automatically do that and so there's
been follow-up work which does exactly
that
so if we can do all of this we can make
it automatic or as I like to say crowd
Ematic and we can remove the machine
learning person entirely from researcher
from the so we've talked about you know
the simple stuff of crowdsourcing labels
and judgments and now let's talk about
crowdsourcing representations and of
course you can use active learning to
save effort and we'll talk about
similarity kernel sort of based first
representations versus feature based
representations so for the crowd kernel
problem you get a bunch of images and
let's just think of questions of the
form of triples is let's say image X I'm
more like XJ or XK so we're just going
to ask these binary questions to people
people are noisy you know I mean if your
people give they're not going to be
consistent people have their own and
judgments may be an individual wouldn't
even be consistent if you ask them twice
on two different days and our goal is to
output a similarity matrix which is a
positive semi definite kernel like just
basically how similar are every pair of
items or you can think of that
equivalently as a embedding of items
into some higher dimensional space but
in general and I'm happy to kind of I
mean maybe I won't go to the great
detail on the active learning algorithm
here because I think more interesting is
sort of the interaction with a crowd and
the different options but this works for
any the nice thing is when you're
dealing with a crowd this works for any
kind of data set it doesn't matter they
don't have to be as long as they can
understand it they can move on so we can
take let's say we get tons of product
categories from Amazon very easily so
here's a bunch of floor tiles and then I
threw in a couple pictures here of Emma
and Robert see what the crowd would
think of them so we can ask questions on
Mechanical Turk which is this
crowdsourcing platform run by Amazon we
can ask questions for like a penny each
I forget that but they're very fast they
like to answer these questions so yeah
you know what might stress you out they
just they're just being paid you use
your judgment is this more like that or
that make a decision is this more like
that or that at the beginning we're
gonna randomly choose our questions and
then these are adaptively chosen with
active learning to get better and better
questions so that we're asking more and
more interesting questions and we're
maybe a finer and finer understanding of
different objects and what you get is an
embedding of the items into Euclidean
space may answer kind of randomly they
may get a reasonable decision you're
saying if Rob is more similar yeah
they'll give you an answer they have no
choice they have to they have to choose
one of the other we didn't give them at
like no opinion Epson yeah so you know
so maybe in this case maybe Rob kind of
looked like the numbers he was on a
background of and if you can see there's
like a black board in the background
list of equations anyway and then you
could imagine all kinds of nature if
this video will play but
you could imagine using this on any date
on any kind of data set and you could
imagine using it as a way to like find
we had an application where you could
search through any face of any
researcher and Microsoft if you forgot
their name but you remembered their face
how could you find somebody with like a
few clicks or you could be shopping for
products and a thing and this will work
you click in and zoom in on the cluster
and you keep getting closer and closer
until you find the item and it was
really fun we did it on any kind of boat
you could be shopping for ties or on
flags we had it for dog breeds and all
kinds of stuff where you know a
similarity assessment is a little
difficult to make yes they did you find
that in general they're sort of unfazed
they're just randomly pick something but
that's a great question for the next
slide so let me just skip over it
let me I'm gonna actually so I go till
when do I go till okay well let me I'll
change the ordinance for that question
by giving the example first and then
we'll come back so here so Sanders
question is like what about a really
tough question yeah so how about we did
this experiment this is actually some
crack adacia suggestion what about the
letters of the alphabet is e more like s
than you what a random question right
how many people here think e is more
like s how many people think e is more
like you okay so there was a mix so some
people thought it was more like s why do
you think he is one I guess why do you
think he is more like you okay so people
are using different no no but you're
both right wait no don't be sad you know
so and some people made their own
decisions and what we were really happy
with was that we could find we could
actually benefit from the diversity of
the crowd here so we could after we got
all these answers we could then use our
so you use our algorithm you get a
representation in Euclidean space and
you can show there's a large margin
separator between vowels and consonants
and there's a large margin separator
that
so there's actually like it captures
sort of tall and short letters and
alphabetical order and also probably the
round versus flat shape of different
letters so you can actually benefit from
the fact that the crowd answers
questions differently
so let me just mention how the algorithm
work so basically and it works this is
just showing you that by nearest
neighbor from the embedding that it
seems to kind of work and that rabbit is
in fact close to the numbers so how does
it work so we start by asking Mechanical
Turk workers to answer questions for
random triples and then we loop where we
fit our model we fit a model to all the
data so far and then we ask for the most
informative triples so that's that style
of active learning so the model we have
is a similar to other models which have
been proposed by limit hour where
instead of saying it's a binary answer
yes no we say people answer
probabilistically and the probability
that they'll say something is I is
closer to J than K is proportional to
the distance let's say or the squared
distance between the two items so if
they're distance 0 it'll be definitely
closer and so on and then we add a
regularization term so that even if so
that no two items are a thing good thing
about as note items being distance zero
apart and it turns out that this problem
unfortunately is not a fitting just even
fitting the model given a bunch of
observations is not a convex
optimization problem but we can show
that we can still solve it assuming in
sort of a realizable case where people
are answering according to if they were
really answering according to a
probabilistic model like this then
stochastic gradient descent will still
converge to the correct model and then
the question is so weak so we're
positioning we're estimating the
similarity matrix and then and then the
question is which triple - it's a query
next and we use some kind of information
great game criteria with a prior I can
go in but but into the details but I'm
not sure it's that useful and and it's
sort of but it did in practice also save
a bunch of queries when
when we when we did that ran that so it
ran this algorithm compared to just
creating random triples would you say
the same performance are you evaluating
also based on the triggers yes so the
way we evaluate is we we have sort of 20
questions game where you imagine that
the the person is you know picking one
of these items just shopping for one of
these items and then you get to ask that
let's say 20 questions is it more
similar to this or that and you want to
see how how many questions it takes you
or how how after 20 questions how
high-ranked is your estimate of the
position of this item so this is in
contrast to sort of another active
learning approach which you could talk
about like the closest to the margin
active learning which I've also worked
on with sentiment and just a small point
is that in these probabilistic settings
sometimes that one is very tricky like
you know the idea the inspiration behind
choosing something closest to the margin
could run into problems if if something
is very close to the margin you know
it's close we know it's close to 50/50
people will certainly answer this very
very close to 50/50 why would we ask
that that's not very informative to us
where is this sort of information gain
criteria might be more helpful
would you suggest having sort of a don't
know well no we'll let the workers
answer but but I'm saying this won't
improve our like entropy of the rep of
the distribution of items right because
the answer will be we could ask a
hundred people after asking a million
people they would still know that this
item is halfway between these two items
yeah so they represent eight things
we'll move around much
um okay so you do get sort of reasonable
questions over time and these questions
could sort of be this particular model
will will favor Ford sort of questions
that are not that too extreme as well
yeah the matrix
yeah the matrix is N squared but in a
dream world we could actually learn this
N squared matrix with only like imagine
hypothetically like n log n queries
maybe because if there's a structure to
it you could actually and they'll become
more yeah is this a different
probabilistic model for how humans
answer the judgment or this is this is
the same oh sorry no you're right what I
meant to say here is if you used a more
standard logistic model thank you you
understand my slide better if you use
the more standard logistic model you
would end up with these very extreme
queries where you you you get it tended
we tried a more standard model intended
to ask these more extreme questions
whereas if you use the distance based
one where things are proportional to the
distances you get the intuition is two
exponential
yeah we because thing I mean I think
it's just a mismatch between the model
and the way people answer questions
people have being close near nearby
things tend to be yeah I think I think
your intuition is probably better than
once again
how do we weigh yes we thought of it as
a batch problem where we had all the
items up front but you're right you
could definitely think of it as an
online problem where you got one a new
item at a time and then you would
imagine that over time your query
strategy would would evolve essentially
into a tree right like you fir this is
the first question you ask after this
you ask this question or that question
and the tree or branching program and
stuff so there's some fun things to
think about here for for an online
problem as well I think so the way we
talked about information gain was we
said okay now we have an item we want to
know which of the pairs to query it on
is this most similar to and we need to
choose a pair of items so we actually
pretend that this item is a random we
have you know we've already fit the
model so we have an embedding of points
in space or similarities we pretend that
this item is actually a random one of
the other items in in the in the data
it's kind of weird but we assume that
the data that the you know the sample we
have enough sample isn't enough we start
with a random triple to sort of get a
reasonable approximation of the space
just okay this item is maybe what if it
were a random one of the other items and
we just don't know which one what
question could we ask that would give us
the most information about which one
it's likely to be so we start with a
uniform prior over where it is which
which of the other items it is if we
were to ask one question that would help
us understand which one it is combined
with the data we already have about the
item yeah search well we were I think we
did this once per item so for each item
we did it once but yes so it was an
cubed algorithm but typically like for
crowdsourcing item like this I mean
since humans are involved they're gonna
do n I ain't know if they're gonna do
ends and queries that's you know n
dollars or whatever you know and there's
a and cubed you can't be the runtime is
typically not the biggest effect but
there could try to come up with a more
efficient algorithm
there might be an issue because
difficult questions might also lead to
difficult questions for computers might
also be difficult for humans so for the
very information questions for the
algorithms those questions can be very
hard for humans to answer so if I am
presented with this kind of question is
this feature more like just get you know
fifty to fifty right
yeah our model would predict that they'd
be 50/50 so therefore the answer would
not be very informative yes so the
humans might not be they're very helpful
yeah so we wouldn't ask this question
because we would say if our model was a
good fit we would say that it's so we
think about anything like a lot elective
to the human we would say this is not a
good question you could ask you could
add that that would be fine
it didn't seem to matter because we
would just get 50/50 kind of interest or
at least did that would be fine I mean
yeah but I think they were just fine we
just told them you know make you use
your best judgment yeah didn't seem to
be a big stressor and now we'll see kind
of the more Allah let me skip there we
did this and all kinds of datasets and
it was fun but um and then people
generalize this exactly to where the
reaction you're asking about about using
removing the human from the loop
entirely so that then they can label
future examples using machine learning
so they can get a good embedding using
the human get a good representation
using the humans and then there's this a
nice snack system where they did it with
food but I mean you could do it with any
domain and they were able to get a good
embedding that would then be useful in
other places all using
okay here's another application missus
joint work with komolika and jamesu
where what we did is we said maybe you
know when you start doing this with
faces or something you feel like yeah
this embedding representation is your
your you're losing a lot of information
that every human has there's there's a
lot of knowledge we know that you know I
mean you look at a face you can say
whether you think it's male or female
where they're wearing glasses are
smiling and all these features and those
are explicit features and if you ask
them is this person more similar to that
one or that one it's kind of a tough
call but I can tell you very right well
you two are similar cuz you're both
wearing glasses beauty recently you know
there's all kinds of reasons that people
are similar in you so anyway why not
just ask for those features in the cases
where there's obvious features let's
just get the crowd to give us the
features themselves okay and the goal is
to get many features have the features
be the salient the ones that stand out
the obvious feature is not the third
pixels red or something and you want
them to be different you don't to keep
getting the same features over and over
and you want to do it efficiently you
want to save money
okay so here's an example of this is the
most standard like if you try to open a
Mechanical Turk account this is an
example of a test they give you this
picture I put in but what would you well
what three tags would you give this
picture if you had to give a tag for
this this is what a crowd worker might
be asked if you were a crowd worker what
would you say waving smiling okay man
good so we did that we took this this
has turns out to be a data set of
somebody doing science at American Sign
Language okay science and we took ten
images and we asked people to to label
them all with three tags and it was fun
because all of the tags they gave could
have applied equally well to any image
in the data set they're all men they're
pretty much all waving in some way or
another and I forget what the other one
was smiling okay then that all admire
smiling but it's pretty irrelevant
whether or not he's smiling maybe is
kind of smiling most of them but so I
like this Vladimir Lenin but anyway
so obviously the right approach is not
to ask them on an image by image basis
what the right features are but the
right approach is to show them the whole
data set and try to understand the
differences which between the different
features okay so we would end up with a
bunch of features in the standard
approach where all the images were mail
signal balled all of them 100 at 100
this would be a terrible sort of user
interface if you're trying to search for
a sign this is useful right like if you
had to find there's somebody who did a
project honestly you want to find look
up a sign in sign language
what's the dictionary for sign language
like right I mean people are gesturing
it's if you see a gesture and you don't
know what it is how do you look it up is
trying to learn sign language so instead
we go in back to kindergarten and this
is not just us this is a standard
approach that's been used in a number of
papers and crowdsourcing and enough
Debbie's here but so you might say you
know which one is different here and so
we would all agree that maybe that's why
is that different
it's a shark I mean so that's not a good
question so it's better to ask what's
common to the things and then you won't
say it's not that they're not sharks
it's that they're all vehicles right so
so it's good to ask questions of the
form what's coming to a set of items and
even though computer scientists will say
there's no difference between what's
asking come in two XY and Z or what's
different than that it could also say
not good people tend to tend it not to
say oh they're not sharks you know they
tended to look for a positive feature
that they all had in common although
sometimes that I'm so we called these
two out of three comparisons and we
would give somebody let's say three
items and say okay what's common to two
out of them and sure enough they would
say I got two hands right and that was
actually the most common difference
between images and what's common to
these well again these two are using one
hand okay so if we did an experiment we
just gave them random triples and this
60% of the answers were all just whether
they were using one or two hands so
that's obviously an opportunity for
active learning and this is actually
like a really really easy win for active
learning and it really worked well so
what do we do instead is a once we get
so the idea is once we get a feature
from the crowd we're gonna ask the crowd
we're gonna show them three images
they're gonna give us a feature we're
then gonna use a crowd to label the rest
of the images because anyway we wanted
to get labels for all the features we
have so our goal actually is the input
is a bunch of images our goal is to get
a bunch of features and label the data
according to the features anyway we've
got the crowd there it's such a great
opportunity so once we get a feature we
immediately label all the examples with
that feature and now there's no point in
asking about a triple that we already
know something that distinguishes them
so we would avoid asking about this new
feature so so the algorithm here I'll
just give it by example so let's say the
features we learned so far are male
female black hair so we're gonna pick
bunches again an N cubed algorithm we'll
just pick a bunch of random triples and
we'll say okay some of these triples
well we won't ask these two three
because they're distinguished by female
and we won't ask some other one because
they're distinguished by black hair
so we'll these are the these are well
most of them are split up by gender
anyway so then but these we had we don't
have an answer to so we can pick one of
these triples and so so starting from
the beginning we'll take a triple a
random triple we'll say okay somebody
will give us that their male will then
go label ask the crowd to label all the
other images according which ones they
think are male and then you know we'll
give them another triple which isn't
resolved and then somebody will say I
clean shaven and then we'll go label all
the images according to clean shaven and
so on female but this will prevent us
from asking either male or female with
clean shaven again and it also prevents
enough there's been similar systems
without active learning and what they
typically run into is the fact that
people use different words for the same
concept male man you know whatever boy
and our representation we won't even get
another description of this because once
we've got hopefully one feature we want
to ask about the same we won't get the
same feature again and again so we can
analyze this under two toys some shion's
one assumption is sort of a hierarchical
model which you know the world is split
into some kind of binary tree
another is under the independence
feature is its very opposite model where
things are where there's independent
features and an iid assumption these are
two very opposite models neither one of
them is realistic the world is not a
binary tree the world is not a bunch of
independent features but maybe if you
can show that your algorithm works in
both cases then maybe that's some
intuition that it's a reasonable
algorithm so right yes eventually well I
mean in this example here they would
always be able to come up with a
distinguishing feature so given any
three items in a binary tree there's
always a distinguishing feature I don't
remember if we gave them an option to
like bail and an ocular feature and you
can also put in quality controls so if
somebody gives you a bad feature that
doesn't make sense when you have people
label it and maybe have three people
label the feature for each example you
see there's Latin that a lot of
agreement yeah exactly that's what
happens in in theory at least
so yeah given any three items in a kind
of a binary tree setting you can see
that you have two choices actually in
this case you can either say these two
are the same because they're both birds
or you can say they're both the same
because they're both natural and it's
kind of neat one of them I forget
whether the generalist or the
specificity are der for us as active
learners like there's an N squared
versus and keep the k-member the
difference but anyway you can think
about these two different types of ways
of answering questions and it's not too
hard to show that well not too hard even
to see I don't know if I'll have time to
go through the proof itself but it's not
very hard to see that actually every
time you ask a triple an unresolved
triple you'll find out about a new node
on this in this tree and there's only if
there's n items there's only n minus one
nodes so or if you're in D dimensions D
features then
it'll take you d queries whereas if you
are using a non adaptive approach it
would take you sort of d cubed queries
it should take you decrypt queries just
to find three items to to find each
feature and I can show you why in the
independent feature case again it takes
you order D features and it takes you
actually exponentially many queries to
find these things out it's there's not a
lot of hard hard math here but let me
just show you the simple analysis here
for the hierarchical case so given any
three items you can always go up to tree
until two of them are under a common
node and the third one isn't and so
there's always a feature every triple
has a feature that that distinguishes it
at least one so there's always an answer
and every moreover every feature like
natural has a triple for which it's or
animal let's say has a triple for which
it's the only answer you can give that's
a little harder to see but not too hard
you need something on the right here
something on the left here and that
actually would not be the feature
because they could have said animal or
natural but had we chosen let's say a
plant no sorry if we want an animal is
that somebody help me here every feature
has a triple four which is a unique
two-thirds so this feature we would have
had to say yeah these two and a plant
that I get the wrong example here anyway
yeah there's always a triple yeah that
would have been the right one the only
answer to this one is animal so okay and
by design will never rediscover feature
so we'll take us order number of nodes
in this tree to find all the features
and not adaptive algorithm if you don't
do active learning how do you know you
might need DQ features well in order to
guarantee that we'll find this bird
feature the only way we can guarantee
that we're able to find the bird feature
what if we're dealing with somebody
who's a generalist the only way we can
guarantee to find the bird features if
we choose these three items otherwise
we're out of luck and if we're just
choosing a non adaptive algorithm that
doesn't know anything about the data it
has to land on that triple by luck and
so it'll take n cubed you see what I
mean because if if I chose these two and
something else they could have always
said natural or some other answer
so without the modeling the only danger
is that somebody would pick a feature
that really doesn't apply no they would
keep I think it's more that they would
keep choosing this two-handed feature
he'd keep getting these very very
high-level features and in order to find
a feature that distinguishes you know in
sign language that they were you know
using their thumb or some very peculiar
feature that they're using their left
them you would need three thumb three
images of where they're using their
thumb but two of them they're using they
left them and when they're using the
right thumb or something actually I
don't think they handle but anyway you
know and so the chance of picking that
at random would be very unlikely but
once you start using an active algorithm
you'll realize oh okay so now I realize
that all these images are using thumbs
let me see what's distinguishing these
different thumb images and then they'll
say okay well this one is using both
thumbs this one's you know you said I
mean so it's actually the concern is
that you just keep get and it's a real
phenomenon you will if you just pick
random images you won't get at the
fine-grained details of the data set
because you won't hone it you need three
kind of very similar examples in order
to get at these fine grained features so
I think we we did it on a few data sets
of faces sign language and flags and
Ornette flags I think it was a mixed
product data set and just to tell you
that yes we got many more features
oops many more features using the
adaptive algorithm than random triples
and many more different different
features so that kind of worked as as we
expected which is not usually a case for
my experiments they usually don't work
at you anyway
you know robust we didn't throw away
features we just would have people label
them and I think we didn't end up I
don't think we ended up I'm trying to
member but I don't think we had a
process for throwing away features in
our experiment right we just take
majority of three people's opinions and
call that the truth yeah I don't think
but I was saying that we could add that
to the system there's many ways you
could improve it and get better features
you could also get better words for
things maybe somebody misspelled and
label our system doesn't ask people to
improve on those or anything like that
so just mention a fun a couple other fun
things you could do with a crowd this is
not my work this is a some work about it
for people and I think it's a great
example of crowdsourcing really the high
level so you imagine you want computers
to program for us one day right and
there's this idea of programming by
example or programming by natural
language where you say okay I have a
string and help me get the last number
out you describe it in English get the
last number from the string and you give
some examples foo 12 is 12 and 54
divided bar that should be 55 okay and
that's all we want to do as programmer
we want the computer to figure it out
but now there's a bunch of edge cases
and a bunch of like the computer might
need many more than two examples but
that's where the crowd could come in the
crowd could come in if the crowd can
understand in English from this
description in these examples what you
want on all these other cases the crowd
can provide further labeled examples
which can be enough for programming by
example system to then go ahead and
generalize I think that's kind of cool
idea so we've talked about the steps of
machine learning which were choosing
representation labeling the data and
running a ml algorithm what's the
missing step that there's one step that
I didn't mention beforehand yes
choose the problem actually and then
there's something else in between
choosing the problem and getting the
representation for the data yeah so we
can actually have the crowd choose the
problem and get the data this is just a
silly kind of fun experiment we didn't
ever publish it but we said hey help us
how can you get the crowd to choose
for you and you say go to crowding say
help us brainstorm some interesting
machine learning problems based on a
data set that will create they had no
idea what we wanted so we rephrased it
and said help to help us invent a fun
game guest blank from a picture of blank
okay and then they were very good they
said guess the gender from a picture of
handwriting so that was the most common
one that people suggested but they also
had fun ones where they said try to
guess guess guess what color eyes I have
from picture of me oh and my eyes closed
but they really understood this and we
could have made all kinds of datasets we
went ahead and did that for the
handwriting one where you had the crowd
then just take pictures of their
handwriting with their phone and send it
in and tell us whether they made a woman
you can build a classifier blah blah
blah so you can actually really remove
the machine learning researcher okay so
conclusion the crowdsourcing can help
machine learning by finding you know
interesting problems questions I didn't
mention that but finding interesting
models and representations really using
hopefully the intelligence of the crowd
and interesting ways active learning can
definitely help us make crowdsourcing
more efficient and more practical save
money and you know hopefully long term
this combination of crowdsourcing
machine learning can help us make you
know accommodation of neural networks
artificial neural networks and real
neural networks can help us make
progress and help computers understand
the other thing the the interesting
machine learning problems thank you so
amount of features that that crowd is
suggestive how many of those would you
say are easy
that's a good question how many of the
features were see if I have some of them
I bet you that um so these were examples
of real features male clean-shaven
female not wearing all of these by now
machine learning algorithms could
totally classify but if you were to ask
in an unsupervised and unsupervised a
machine learning algorithm to come up
with features for faces I bet you they
wouldn't come up with those feature
necessarily those features you said I
mean an unsupervised algorithm comes up
with the clusters faces or whatever I
don't know if it would cluster them in
in ways that we would find as intuitive
have you done things not in the vision
domain like something you did vision
just because it's so fast and efficient
but no but these things could be used
for listening to audio or things like
that but in our cases it is helpful that
the crowd we chose specifically domains
where the crowd could understand them
quickly but nobody haven't done that
experiment it's a good question I think
people have done experiments on audio
like trying to represent sounds thank
you very much
[Applause]